[Music]
hey everybody adam and eve is still
offering amazing prices at
adamandeve.com get 50 off plus free
shipping that is 50 off an adventurous
new toy a slippery lube or almost
anything else you desire that's crazy
and our podcast listeners will get 50
off almost any item just use code
lifeline at checkout and you'll get 50
off and guess what that's not all why
because free shipping sometimes shipping
costs an arm and a leg not here not with
adam and eve crazy it doesn't matter
what you choose everything will be
packaged and sent discreetly for free
not only will you save money on gas
movies and date night dinners out but
this is the item that will continue to
save you money deliver tons of fun and
satisfaction yeah so go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
code lifeline that's l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e
this is an exclusive offer specific to
this podcast so be sure to support our
show and use the code lifeline to get
you not just the 50 off but also the 100
free shipping code lifeline go to
animeneve.com
right now right now
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
hello
[Music]
why are you hello it like that that's a
terrible idea what that is a terrible
idea what
well because i have to do my show dates
are we starting
okay we're started guys listen first of
all before we start i'm gonna
start by taking some pure spectrum
gummies and why are you feeling bad no
it's just i keep it i keep taking the
gummies i keep doing the
drop dropper is that it
no
there's no thc it's awesome and it keeps
me at a certain level that i love and if
you want to get 10 off
see the show notes for details under the
youtube video and you can click on that
link and then type in code congrats you
get 10 off all cbd products it's great
and uh yeah whatever we're in uh this is
live you want to know about me i do yeah
but first i want to say
the tour has been going great all right
okay i was in dallas and i was in
wichita and i also am going to
savannah
georgia and raleigh north carolina
and i can't wait to do either of those
because the van is supposed to be
beautiful and raleigh is [ __ ] awesome
i've been there before and it's where
kristen is from ah
yep and calvin's coming and kristen's
coming and i'll be doing raleigh so
raleigh north carolina but i also got
denver and boston so go
oh and i want to tease
striptease nope
i want to tease new york city and
chicago coming up back to back dude i'm
going new york in chicago i've been to
new york city okay well yeah you've been
there a lot i've lived there piano
for years i've lived there for years
pinot
pino
pino
pinio
pino
pinio why are you doing it
new york big city of dreams everything
in new york oh yeah yeah yeah snoop and
dad's all big over the city
pinion
pinion
pinion
pinion pino makes me think of penises
though okay well that's not what that
song is
about i wonder what freud would say
about that you know what i'm saying
uh so i noticed snoop dogg um did you
say pino pineal do you want to know
about me
yes
so what i've been doing
uh i've had my first day of sessions
giving advice advice to you
you go to mattalia.com you book an
appointment 20 or 40 minutes i had a
full last day my first day was a full
ass day gave some great [ __ ] advice
everyone advice that came to me i
appreciate you all i love you all you're
all very sweet and cool and kind and
thank you probably not all of you thank
you thank you know all of them probably
not all
of them so far so good i will say that
probably one or two
so get your appointment now attend uh
i'll tell you what we'll talk to you
soon what
uh
it's very uncomfortable so much tower
the last day i sit really nice i sit
straight i've always sat straight okay
but just so everyone knows he's like
half an inch taller than me not eight
inches taller than me what is this no
dude i am uh i'm i'm i'm an inch maybe
taller than you maybe maybe yeah but
you you know my my my podcast wow my
is infinitely better than yours is that
it is yeah but look how pimp and pimping
it is when i chill back like this but
i'm pimping me too i don't think you are
you look uh nervous that's fine but
nobody is sits more paper than i do and
you know that well see now you leaned
back into it like and you took me you
took your page from me in the book i
write on how to sit and you're being
more pimping around
to do it
wow dude i'm putting a drink
this on vacation dude that one dad takes
takes
like
a picture on vacation it's like he's
trying to cram his arms
yeah in as tight as he possibly can so
if somebody was standing behind him it
would look like he had no arms he's a
contortionist yes dude he whenever he
was on the gondola and we were doing
like this and we were in italy and he
was doing it like this he looked the way
that's taken a picture and i didn't
realize it when i realized that i
laughed so hard yeah i i do remember
that okay but also i sit very cool and
and you know that dude a lot of people
say i sit like bon jovi and a lot of
people say i sit with no respect
but that's not cool at all to have no
respect for something let's let's all
get this straight i agree with it it is
not cool to present as if you have no
respect i i i think there's a difference
between having no respect and being
comfortable within your own body showing
the respect you have for yourself and
sitting the way you want to yes got out
of that one how about me and barney
though no no no we were going to talk
about this what about barney me and no i
i think
sitting the way you want i don't like
when people are like dude sometimes i
like i have my foot up
i'm like at the bottom of a chair dude
all the time oh so i don't sit erect
then so i do sit chill and chill in okay
fine okay so i got you but it's not
pimping pimping you sit chilling
chilling you don't give a pimp so my
point is i have the foot up and people
will be like take your foot off and they
don't even [ __ ] have anything to do
with where we are it's just like i'm at
a cafe and some customer is like dude
you shouldn't have your foot on the
thing and i'm like dude
customers yeah yeah it's happened that's
really the last time it happened was a
patient at a doctor's office i was at
the doctor's office i had my foot up on
the the seat part of the seat
on the wall or in some [ __ ] like so when
you say the seat part of the seat what
do you mean the part you sit on
that part so that person didn't want the
the bottom of your shoe touching where
his ass might go her her ass of course
her an old lady she was like i don't
think you should be having your foot on
the seat speaking of mean old ladies
dude i got into an elevator and i was
with someone we were going down
and it was a smaller elevator there were
two elevators one was bigger one was
smaller the small one came
and these in this building the elevators
take a while okay uh the old woman goes
in because we obviously let her go
because we have [ __ ] manners yeah of
course and then the two of us get in the
elevator too because
we want to get on the elevator of course
yeah okay so we both walk on and she's
making a big production
and then before the door is closed yeah
she goes two
oh and i said i was like i was like
taking it back i was like oh sorry what
and she says two
and then before i could even realize
what she meant she just gets off the
elevator and then i saw and then i
realized she meant
hit number two it only there only two
people are allowed on this elevator what
because i decided that
and as if i was supposed to know that
to her she wanted only two of us on the
elevator
uh you sure that's what she meant
how
though because when we got
when we got to the lobby again
there's a tiny sign near the entrance
that says something about the small
elevator can only only two people can
write it but also that was like from the
beginning of the pandemic
is like a [ __ ] few weeks ago yeah
anyway two
wow dude that's horrible to do that i
don't like when people are like that uh
also i'll do it if you ask nice if she
says excuse me of course dude are you
kidding me you're scared like of course
i'll take the next course so would i
of course i'll kick you out and make you
take the next one
two oh i'm sorry ma'am here why don't we
i'll show you out just pick her up like
this
shh yep
why are the two elevators different
sizes what kind of weird fun house were
you in i don't know that's so high but
there were two elevators different sizes
it was like a medical building i think
one was for service big ass things
oops oops right i'll make it a joke
right you're asking yeah and then i'm
making a joke before me i'm asking and
then immediately while i'm answered
you're toppling me but that's because
that's what humor is i'm doing it with
humor that's not that's not what it is
and oops is like interrupt to be like oh
yeah by the way today
no i think you're doing a joke you asked
me a question and immediately when i
start answering you start d
toppling me
what oh this [ __ ] behind that behind the
back no andrew dice no
all right so um yeah don't go oops if
i'm doing a joke dude do not do that i
didn't i said oops oops yeah you're not
gonna so it was two of them um
i'll get we'll be honest with you guys
if i was watching this podcast and this
is the first time i watched the podcast
i turned off and ever watch it again no
way dude i think the opposite i would be
like what is this podcast i'd be like
these guys are [ __ ] look at that
guy's pink shirt it's great
i got white shirts i [ __ ] don't know
writing on it send you know if you're
lucky you'll be able to see that who
knows who knows what might happen the
rest of this hour
yeah you could see my shorts
stay tuned
worst stay tuned
you might see my shorts after these
messages
we'll be right back dude hell yeah all
right so uh do you want to get into it
or what it's already too hot so i'm
[ __ ] that's awesome i'm not that i'm
always talking about hot right now
there's been a heat wave in los angeles
108 degrees the other day it was
108
degrees dude let me tell you something i
hate when you talk about the weather and
someone's like oh are we so boring we
talk about the weather [ __ ] when
it's 108 degrees yeah yeah
you
you weren't even digesting what i was
saying at that point and i have an issue
with it i wasn't no i didn't even hear
you there we go yeah so no i was not
only not digesting it i didn't even put
in my mouth
in my mouth digesting i'm using your
metaphor
i said it was 108 degrees as i was
saying it was 108 degrees you were going
and then when i was done talking you
said it was 108 degrees i already said
that part so basically what you were not
we're doing is we're not listening
and then we're done being redundant i i
i listed it to you and i knew what
you're gonna say and i took the deep
breath in so i could hit it right when
you finished saying the word degrees yes
it's shitty
it's not shitty
it's good
[Laughter]
it's kind of like what dad does actually
yeah i know you know what i mean i know
and we all we both agree that we what we
hate that so okay yeah all right um well
that's how i kind of like it though
after years of hating it's like
tradition you know what i'm saying well
yeah okay i get it all right so look
let's go i'm gonna uh you know
we're gonna i got crazy good advices i
don't know what the videos are yet but
let's do it dude we'd like to get a
fresh take on it let's go number one
hello chris and matt
juliette and i'm 49 years old i'm cuban
i live in miami florida i've been a fan
of chris for many years and now i love
the both of you thank you i have a
question i get fired from every job i
have because
when i'm about to get my period i lose
my temper and that gets me in trouble
now a few people suggested that i do a
podcast
also only fans right now my question is
49
is it too late no no we're only fans
she's beautiful
okay
wow
what do you guys think
not too long thank you that sounds
delicious
but also even if she wasn't even if she
wasn't dude it's not too late 49 is not
dude there are men who have specific
fetishes for women way older than that
my whole thing is oh you're acting like
there's not lonely souls that are your
age yeah but you're acting like there's
not lonely souls in this [ __ ]
planet of 8 billion people you don't
think [ __ ]
25
lonely souls why are you saying it like
that we'll we'll [ __ ] sign up for
your only fans and give you 20 bucks a
month how many and that's yaper dude how
many i'm just saying you can find 20
lonely souls to just [ __ ] subscribe
to your only fans but also podcasts way
different than an only fan just do you
know podcasts
yeah showing your tatas i mean way
easier if you want to do a podcast do it
but you're gonna make if you're talking
about jobs and lifestyle and living
wage of cost of living [ __ ] yeah the
only fans is the way to go okay yeah do
the podcast as well and pump up the
podcast on your only fans
push people while you're naked one feeds
the other pushing push them towards the
podcast you get more viewers more
listeners yeah also
anyone who sounds like this that's from
the south of miami
absolutely
pops off at the mouth and gets fired so
that i mean you know like that there's
no way dude she's like a like a classic
like
firecracker thing yeah yeah i mean you
could see her being like well that's
actually not how you're going to talk to
me right right right i'm out of here and
walks away with blood blood like
dripping down her leg
i know but not her [ __ ]
it's not gross it's graphic and crafts
so beautiful and one thing about me is
that i'm not crass so then beautiful red
light would not blood
what how would i make it it happens it's
natural so how would i say it
to make it not crash you wouldn't say it
that's how it would work best so we're
denying it so again you're sexist oh yes
gotta do that one it's beautiful and
it's natural some women rub it on their
faces but i'm not saying she's also not
from the south of florida she's from
cuba obviously that's why i'm saying i
was trying to not be racist about the
whole popping up at the mouth
you were racist anyway okay but cubans
go like this you actually not gonna talk
to me like that yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean and uh [ __ ] rule let's
get started they rule yeah oh they rule
okay but they also
you know they pop up they're fiery
they're passionate people exactly
everything good and also bad like they'd
be like wow this food is so amazing i
can't believe it what i'm tasting right
now this is unbelievable i love this
food it's so good and you're like all
right yeah it's very good just relax but
i can't stop thinking about that and
then when someone falls off the plate
they're all you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
flip the plate over [ __ ] all this place
never coming again wow i'm saying
passion on everything right i [ __ ] up
when i was doing both extremes yeah and
um
and so uh yeah so you could start at
only fans it depends you need to figure
out what kind of only fans you want to
do right you want to show your your your
your boobs or your feet right totally
different stories you get more
money for your boobs obviously right
because of what i know how many people
lonely souls yeah i know what is that i
don't know dude i do not understand the
foot fetish thing so many of you have
that [ __ ] dude and i'll tell you what i
don't understand it and i'll tell you
what i've tried what do you mean i've
sat there and looked at feet and been
like let's try and work this out you
know work this out
because it would be nice to have a
[ __ ] kinks are nice
you got a kink that's an extra thing in
your life there's certainly nothing
wrong with them but to try to have a
kink is not going to work kinks the
whole thing about a kink is that it's
like ah i can't help it it's like i love
[ __ ] you know
uh belly buttons or whatever the [ __ ]
you know i don't do like belly buttons
but yeah okay
um but yes you can start start with the
podcast try a podcast it might be okay
you keep getting fired become your own
boss that's what that's what that's what
she's getting she's getting it become
your own boss you don't even realize you
may be getting at that become your own
boss start a business you can do it get
you know you can sell stuff on [ __ ]
whatever it is
which is what she's already volunteering
she might want to do the answer is all
signs [ __ ] go do the only fantasy yes
do the podcast yes but what i'm saying
is she might not be realizing that the
true thing she wants is just to be her
own boss she might not want to start a
podcast
so i'm just saying think about that for
a little bit and those are my advices
but if the question is simply am i too
old to do only fans no absolutely not
even at all and you know why
lonely soldiers okay right also age not
only does it not matter in this context
or really many contexts unless it's like
athletics
there are specifically men and maybe
even women out there too who have
specific kinks or fetishes for
older women even 49 is not even that old
no it's not old no but yeah like there's
porn sites out there that are like 42
years old either women like 70 year old
women
you know yeah i know yeah and they make
money dude yeah they're driving around
in [ __ ] night you know the nice
version of a [ __ ] whatever the nicest
version is of like a buick a lower end
car yeah oh oh
i thought you meant like an older well
they're not driving [ __ ] uteruses
around town you know what i mean they're
not making that much money they're not
driving through the [ __ ] town what is
it with the tits flopping around
okay so when i talk natural you get
disgusted when i talk natural when when
i talk beauty
you know what an older woman has
okay so their boobs are perky what do
you want me to do a lot oh you said tits
flapping around below the belt
oh they see well that's yeah you could
and it's gross but no i didn't say that
and aegis you're putting words in my
mouth
uh anyway uh not even close to too old
no congrats no way congrats on that yeah
you did it cool and also she looks
fantastic for 49. yeah that's great so
good job good job on that keep going do
do keep doing what you're doing next
what's good matt and chris chris matt um
calling in a day because i need some
advice on living single
ah live and what singing i'm i'm at the
point in my life now where i'm starting
to realize like
maybe
i'm the problem you know it's a deeper
yeah but been there for sure like i'm
just tired of the cycle that i have with
dating women like
getting to know him and
i've i've pretty much ruined
every relationship i could i could have
had or had
and i'm at the point where i'm just
tired of it you know like i'd much
rather be by myself if i can't
wake up still get lonely
so
i'm trying to
[Music]
i want to see like do you guys think
it's possible to get to a point where
you're so in tune and
just got it together so well with
yourself where
to the point where you no longer lust
after romantic relationships or even
care about them anymore like oh wow you
guys think it's possible to get to that
point being single and if you do
how do you go about doing that god damn
i mean love some feedback from you guys
appreciate the pod keep killing it love
y'all both thank you bro
thanks for asking to be clear
could you be in a a point where you're
you're not
you're so comfortable lusting after got
it oh man this is me look this is my
this is me
wishing i was in your boat that's me in
another boat just ah wishing you could
be like that [ __ ] yeah dude okay well
here's his happy with nothing is it okay
to be that way absolutely 100
can you live a life like that absolutely
100 however
we are social animals and we do at
certain points
sometimes for some people all the time
for other people
probably like you and frankly also like
me it's it's like less you want or need
that less than maybe most people so you
can go long periods about
being single maybe go on a date here and
there but or or maybe even not who knows
what this guy's talking about but i
think that it's absolutely possible if
that's how you want to live your life
but
what i would absolutely say
i can't emphasize this enough do not
rule out
a potential relationship because you're
so what you have a word you might call
dedicated to being alone and single that
to me when you go over the line it
crosses the line when you're like no i
am absolutely always going to be single
and i decided that and i will never have
a partner that is exhausted into a new
target about it that is but it's
unhealthy it's unhealthy dude it's not
being real with yourself sometimes we do
want a relationship and we need to
remain open to it even if you actually
really would rather be single which i
totally do get go ahead you could that
by the way i've never been so sure that
somebody has woken up an hour and a half
before the video you know like i could
tell by this face i don't know with his
it's on the
back end of being puffy from waking up
you can tell okay
also he couldn't look more like he's
from 1995 and it's all good but that is
a 1995 face
and that is amazing interesting he
couldn't look like if i met him in 1995
i wouldn't think of anything different
i'd just be like hey dude that's a guy
you know what i mean okay
and now what do you think now i go oh
what's he doing now right he took a time
machine yeah yeah yeah okay so um that
guy is uh
fine i mean how old i never can tell
honestly i can't tell how all black
people are i have no idea dude i can't
tell hold anyone white people i can do
and that's pretty much it hell dude i
don't know how old anyone is while
you're looking at my hair so much i i
wasn't okay but but but but black people
are like either
so
25 for so long
or
just have been 60 forever like morgan
freeman so that guy
is 30 or he looked young i mean he could
again i'm bad at guessing every one
person everyone's age in the [ __ ]
world i would guess that guy is like
early 30s yeah okay but it could be in
his late 20s for sure yeah i know 100
um i
i
think that
just careful how selfish you are you
know uh make sure you're doing it
because you feel comfortable and not
necessarily a little selfish do it so
because you feel comfortable not because
you don't want anyone else not because
you don't want love
[ __ ] your life up right like you
don't want to be [ __ ] matt damon and
uh
uh the movie good hunting right
sorry i'm [ __ ] allergic to i didn't
want you to sneeze just now uh that's
okay oh that's crazy and um didn't want
that at all okay though dude wow
and uh yeah dude i i feel like uh
you can be open to it without being like
nah [ __ ] that you know yeah i mean you
can really get into this zone where this
is why i said it was unhealthy you can
get into the zone where you're talking
to yourself all day about it and
convincing yourself that you'd like it
more being single when really you're
just afraid to get in another one and
[ __ ] it up and feel that yeah the pain
of that don't be afraid of that but also
you're clearly aware that you're the as
you put it in the beginning of the video
you might be the problem that is an
amazing step on the way to actual
happiness within with a partner yeah so
if you do get back out there keep that
in mind and and if things come up that
remind you of things in the past how
maybe you would have handled something
before yeah think about how to handle it
in a different way how you might handle
it in a way that isn't going to ruin the
relationship i mean
you definitely uh there's going to be
people out there that you
do date and want to date
try
some new version of yourself that is
comfortable for you hello
[Laughter]
how are you uh well would you like to
eat i always pick yeah you just be
british um
but yeah i think uh it's okay to be
alone and single but you can go over a
line you got to be careful with yourself
yeah keep an eye on yourself so to speak
at 49 he's gonna be like should i start
a podcast and only fans all right let's
do it next
hi guys uh i'm from france so i'm sorry
for the mistakes cool i need your advice
on my situation but it turns out that a
few weeks ago you already gave advice to
a guy who was in the exact same
situation as i am right right now i am
still a virgin at 25. uh the advice you
gave uh the guy a few weeks ago was to
be more social and to get on dating apps
i am already on dating apps i've been
for 10 years but it's difficult to make
meaningful connection on there then
to be more social okay but i have social
anxiety okay
i'm dealing with it i'm in therapy every
everything is working out great still i
don't go out much i like to be at home i
don't drink i don't like parties so yeah
now
here's my problem uh
i don't know how to act around men they
make me uncomfortable once if i like
them
i'm gonna be uncomfortable i don't know
how to act so when they try to flirt
with me i go away you know i'm scared
because i know that i have to tell them
that i'm a virgin and i am scared of
their reactions so i'd rather just bye
and then if i have to explain it there's
gonna be questions like why are your
virgin
how
why
what's the catch with you
nothing
okay i'm just anxious you have to live
with with that
like you're a virgin and maybe you won't
find someone who will understand accept
you and take the time to teach you
everything there is to know most people
are impatient they want to sleep with me
before get getting to know me yeah
so what's your advice
what's your thoughts there's a few
things going on there to be social and
to get on dating why does everyone why
do you bye why do you need to tell them
beforehand
this is your [ __ ] you you're on the show
you run the show yeah yeah i think she
would want to
i think that's fair to want to say that
someone before you have sex with him
i think you're a virgin i mean i i
totally get that but i would say though
there's a few things to that but one of
them i want to get out of the way
and this is something i've come across a
lot because i actually feel the opposite
but
so many men that i know
would
love specifically to meet a virgin and
start a relationship with a virgin i
feel the opposite yeah oh right because
they get jealous of the past and stuff
like they'll be like oh
yeah but also
fetishes it's like a men fetishize this
idea of like someone new to sex they get
to be their first person it's like
that's as old as
i mean i talk about you know they do
that in the tutors all the time like
they were like well i won't marry her if
she's been deflowered you know what i
mean right the tutorials it's a very
old-fashioned it's okay my opinion oops
about the tutors all the time but it's
not it's well i'm done with it okay good
thing i finished it and it was not that
good at the end got worse i know it was
very boring the end got very boring okay
season one was bad season two was okay
three was fine and was bad and no one
cared about any of it but they were like
well they were like
you know they always want they could
they he [ __ ] beheaded a woman because
he thought that she slept with someone
before whoa
that he was you know so he was pissed
she was like you and and and she didn't
even she just he
he thought that and he believed fully
accused yeah so that's i'm just saying
is a bummer right and you're living in a
time now where that doesn't happen you
run the show dude you let yourself
um because here's the thing you're 25 it
gets to a point where
you
now it's like you want to do it but it's
like this thing you know what i'm saying
and you're already kind of there so i'm
not saying
do it to get it over with but yeah you
might be looking for that perfect first
time that doesn't exist that does not
yeah i can vouch for that it just
doesn't exist yeah right yeah um i knew
a very i knew a very
beautiful woman
who was a virgin into her early 30s
and uh she just kind of like this woman
was saying she had she just never met a
guy that she felt comfortable doing with
it and and then as you said at a certain
point it became this big thing that was
like she was too hyper aware of it that
it would like get in the way of her
starting new relationships but i think
telling a guy
is going to be fine a lot of guys are
going to like that so that get that out
of the way put that out of your mind
second of all
them asking you why why why just say
exactly what you said to us because i'm
socially awkward and i never had a
relationship where i felt comfortable
doing that that is totally fine and
normal nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with that nobody would think
there's something wrong with that
uh but
the social anxiety thing what i would
say about when men flirt with you and
you get skittish and go away even if you
like them
if you like them and they're flirting
with you
practice one thing and that is keeping
your feet where they are
don't i was gonna slide away don't
skittle away because it's easier just
stay there and if you get uncomfortable
it's okay because i promise
the guy there is attracted to you and
wants you to stay there too yeah
sometimes it's easier to uh control your
body than it is to control your mind oh
for sure just keep your feet where they
are keep it simple keep your feet when i
first started doing stand up i was like
how am i going to get on that stage and
i literally thought if i just move my
feet forward
step by step to the stage i'll be on the
stage and then i'll have to start
talking and i did that i didn't think
about it i was just like one step two
step come on keep going keep going i got
on stage is that true yeah whoa yeah
tell that story that's [ __ ] weird huh
yeah that you said that and i i've
thought that for years yeah it's funny
it's kind of like a copy of me but yeah
no you do the step i'm talking about
counting the steps you did that
oh weird yep i was like come on keep
going dude you got this okay yeah keep
your feet firm i mean if not like always
when a guy's hitting on you if you don't
like him get the [ __ ] out of there
matt said
[Laughter]
uh
but yeah
long term you're not gonna have a
[ __ ] problem you're like a sweet
funny personable young woman also 25
really is not that it's not that old
yeah all right next
oh my god what's up matt and chris you
guys get a lot of advice questions about
dating co-workers and i just want to get
my input on that since seven years ago i
asked a co-worker to go on a date with
me
and i think it's definitely okay to date
co-workers as long as you read the
situation
and uh you never know where it might be
too
so it led to him never wearing a shirt
uh don't be creepy to me not being able
to hang out he seems to be into you why
not ask her out
and uh
just save the universe but uh say hi to
nala and thanks for the show i saved the
universe high not what i would say to
you i'll hang your pictures up first of
all 2015
ain't 2022 buddy
what does that mean
it means it was a lot easier oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but obviously that's what
i meant and the fact that you asked me
what i meant pisses me i didn't know
that he met her in 2015. but he said
seven years ago okay well so i don't do
the math and i didn't know what he meant
before you asked what i meant i assumed
what you meant i wanted to make sure
dude it's always good to make sure and i
don't like doing i don't like that it is
different i don't think it's wrong i
just think you got to be a lot more
careful now to do it exactly because
you know people will be like
hey fire this guy yeah you can't
willy-nilly do it you can't be a [ __ ]
even remotely like a creep you just got
to be way way way
more careful and smarter uh and not be
like if you only do it this is the
ultimate advice and i think i even said
this at the time only do it
if you really feel there is an actual
connection and it could turn into a real
relationship crazy though what guys are
crazy though so are women what do you
mean what is that yeah because they'll
be like oh this is a [ __ ] this this
means something and they're like she's
like who's that guy that's not it's not
about already believing you have a
special i'm saying if you only do it
only go to that far if you believe
so far as to ask someone to go out with
you at work if you believe there's a
potential long-term relationship that's
all i'm saying all right uh yeah yeah
you're not just trying to [ __ ] you're
saying
i mean no i would say it's a little bit
more specific than that it's not just
trying to rank not just it's not just
it's not not just trying to run it's
like you're you're you're
foreseeing more than just like like
there's somebody you really really like
this is not just some willy-nilly girl
you think is pretty you but
my point is how many friends do you have
that are like oh man she's awesome i
could see a real connection and you're
like okay bro but that's not the best
you can't make these guys unplug their
radars like they still have to trust
something i guess yeah try to avoid it
at all costs but also it would be
hilarious if she went to his work now
and was like
he [ __ ] hit on me mm-hmm
and he'd be like you have two kids yeah
she's like it doesn't matter maybe
uncomfortable you should fire him yeah
they would fire him that's how twisted
now is well people would be so confused
though but that's how twisted now is in
2015 they would be like the [ __ ] out of
you you have two kids now there would be
like a [ __ ] op-ed written about you
you know what i mean interesting
interesting interesting interesting
and now a word from our sponsor better
okay uh betterhelp.com is great um
there is often a mindset that i'm not in
because i get stressed out you know i'm
focused on my problems instead of
solutions and
you know these situations they might go
better with different mindsets and
it can be tough on your brain to stay in
problem-solving mode especially when
faced with these challenges and the
because they're very stressful right uh
but when you learn how to find your own
solutions there's no better feeling
and that can be done here with
betterhelp.com a therapist can help you
become a better problem solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or so small so if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option okay and why it's
super convenient it's accessible it's
affordable and entirely online
comforting your own home yeah hard to
find a therapist out in the world wait
lists and you got to make appointments
deep in the future here on
betterhelp.com you get matched with a
therapist after filling out just a brief
survey and then you can switch
therapists literally at any time yeah
for any reason so look uh therapy saved
my life and it saved many people's lives
i can't
express the importance of it enough uh
so listen when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you there
visit
betterhelp.com lifeline today to get
your 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
lifeline
hey guys so my husband's band is going
to be recording in los angeles for 10
days in december so i'm going to be
tagging along and bringing our
five-month-old baby so i am asking what
can i do for 10 days in los angeles with
a 5 month old baby chris is there
anywhere you like to take calvin
um i really hope you guys answer this
because the google searches are [ __ ]
so
please please let me know i really need
things to do for those 10 days thanks
guys i think there's this question
there's a lot of cool parks i know that
like google might not show you like
they'll show you where the parks are but
like it's so cool because the weather's
nice i don't know where you live but the
weather will be like breezy and crisp
maybe it might be a little too cold in
december when did she say he's coming
december oh december um and if he's five
months now he'll be seven months uh
there's other cool places like um i
don't know what you have or where you're
from but like there's the tar pits is
awesome
carpets is amazing i went to the tar
pits and calvin [ __ ] loved it there's
a video out there that i did bringing
calvin to the surprising calvin it's
called on my youtube
um
and uh
that's cool but my son loves dinosaurs
she said it was a son i don't remember
what she said oh no i think so um but uh
yeah uh and there's like also the museum
of torture or museum of pain oh that's
not good yeah go that yourself leave the
kid home yeah yeah yeah um but also it's
just 10 days
so do tar pit
um
what else
what's your favorite part to take calvin
there's one on well i don't want to
[ __ ] yeah yeah people show up right
right um
yeah
i don't know i don't know
i mean there's the la zoo yeah for sure
but i was so bad with zoos
whatever yeah i know i'm just saying
he's seven months old it exists it's
there oh what about the uh gene autry
museum with all the western stuff
i mean seven months it's so good it's so
young yeah
yeah you know what it doesn't matter
what you do with a seven yeah exactly
yeah you know it really doesn't it's for
you do the stuff you want 100
yeah because the seven months first of
all they're not gonna remember anything
yep okay second of all they're not even
gonna know what they're looking at yeah
with bright colors dude yep go see you
know get a dvd of rio and just [ __ ]
watch it in the hotel yeah it's like
it's just not yeah i think that you know
i don't think it matters i [ __ ] was
even now my son's two and a half and
he's just like today his whole thing was
taking a a squeaky dog toy that's a lion
and bopping a [ __ ] oh i love that
though that game bopping a [ __ ] t-rex
and i'm laughing like hell i love
bopping a [ __ ] t-rex so uh so yeah he
also came down this morning and said
smiles like [ __ ] poop
are you [ __ ] serious yes
and we were like
right did you hear about what he said
that's [ __ ] crazy oh yeah yeah yeah
but that was that the first time you
said it that's the first time you said
crazy it [ __ ] yeah and so now what he
just says it all the time crazy it was
really [ __ ] poop what
that's what that's what that's what the
nanny said what do you do
i say smells like poop
and then he says smells like poop he
says no no it smells like [ __ ] poop
yeah how does he know what i don't know
what we say it enough
he's just he probably thinks of it just
as it's a word for emphasis oops
you jinxed me
i didn't i didn't do anything except say
the word said the same word while i was
saying it as if we were going to do a
duet i didn't say jinx you said emphasis
when i said that's an emphasis
um so yeah so i think just do what you
want to do dude yeah don't go first of
all google is terrible you don't seven
months though they don't know anything
dude
just keep them at the hip and go to cvs
all right
hey chris hey matt thanks for doing this
podcast it's something to look forward
to every single week that's chris it's a
gift to have you back so welcome back
thanks for the laughs
so recently had a situation where i
found out that my cousin got married and
nobody called me texted me invited me to
the wedding that's hilarious i've been
told it's a small wedding but that's not
really what i want to hear growing up as
an only child these were my brothers and
sisters all involved in that side of the
family and it's kind of hurtful to not
be considered to attend that wedding
caveat i live in tampa florida they live
in providence rhode island for some
reason
and i always make the trip up for family
event funeral wedding you name it and i
would have been there so do i say
something or do i let it go big believer
letting it go but i also think that i
can have a conversation with them that
wouldn't be confrontational so curious
to hear your thoughts on that situation
thank you guys both chris see you in
lakeland [ __ ] yeah lakeland we'll be
there for some reason um let me say
something you have a good thing to say
but go ahead and then i'll it's not even
about the advice okay when he's when his
face came up uh-huh i was like this
guy's a horrible [ __ ] is gonna
be so hard-assed oh really he opened his
mouth and that he's like the sweetest oh
[ __ ] most respectful guy yeah not
even trying to [ __ ] one-up you but i
knew he was going to be sweet i love him
i love him okay okay
i want to marry him okay well and we're
going to get married and not invite you
can't do that in florida he's not going
to invite his cousin
uh that's funny good job i'm doing that
i didn't think of it but um
it's fine i should have thought of it
but uh
i think the thing is if you should maybe
bring it up if you feel like you're
close to them and you should have been
invited bring it up but here's how you i
think you bring it up dude uh-oh no no
this is actually good i think i'm giving
good advices right now we'll see you say
listen i know you didn't invite me to
the wedding that's your deal you decide
that
understood i want to know if there's
something that i'm
not
privy to or lacking in in this
relationship that warrants
me not being invited because i feel like
i would have invited you to mine and i
just wonder where your head's at do you
know what i mean
i don't like that
i want you to digest it after the
podcast you're going to love it
so you saying you don't like it is
actually not the case
and it's a little more therapist
i think that puts
you in a precarious position with that
person because that person can can start
to get
uh
[Music]
defensive because they feel like you're
putting a guilt trip on them no no but i
don't think okay so that's why i say
this i don't think this guy would make
it seem guilt trippy maybe maybe that's
why i say it to this guy okay fair
enough but what i would suggest is just
saying plain and simple why are you
doing that
he's [ __ ] flexing
uh i i think you'll feel the moment i
think that you should just plain
especially as you said this it wouldn't
be awkward it would be fine like he
thinks he could bring it up with them i
think you just plainly say hey
i don't want to make this weird at all
but i think about it sometimes and i
just wanted to ask you so i don't have
to think about it anymore can you just
tell me why you didn't invite me to the
wedding it'll be fine no matter what i
just
i really would love to know yes and do
that is good do that
literally fly to the wedding to do that
and ask him that in a suit already oh
wait the wedding didn't already happen
no no and go do it and do it with tears
in your eyes
well yeah for sure if the wedding didn't
happen then definitely do that you're
not invited get on your knees and you're
not yeah i just need to know crying do
you ever think about sometimes what if
these people call in and they're just
a an absolute lunatic and the people
they're talking about they don't even
exist no i thought of that but i do
think about it if they're like
they're waiting to get our advice and
the minute they see it aired they just
do it like right away you know oh yeah
oh do our advice yeah yeah oh that's
hilarious no i i think they probably
don't take our advice anyway yeah no me
too but they should yeah they should
take my advice for sure yeah i'm mine
my mind
sometimes like thirty percent you 100
okay
100
okay what's up hi matt and chris
really love your show
so here's my dilemma
recently i convinced my boyfriend to
stop drinking because he's had a
long-term problem with alcohol and he's
been doing really great hasn't been
drinking for months
but i still work part-time at a bar
and i have late nights that i work
sometimes i'll stay out i'll drink with
some buddies and i know that he resents
me that i get to drink and he doesn't so
i'm trying to decide should i
stay in the job this year and get the
paycheck and hang out with my friends or
should i quit my job for the winter
and
stop drinking in solidarity with my
boyfriend
would love some advice thank you that's
really sweet that you're even thinking
of that um it is
very
it is very honorable to do that
um at the end of the day
you know since you're dealing with
addiction this all has to do with him
being able to do this i think in the
beginning it's it's you know it's if
he's not going to a facility and if he's
trying to do you know quit drinking i
don't know if he's an addict or not but
if he's trying to not drink and you say
he's doing a good job
then he might be able to handle it um
but i think just keep it in mind like i
think that
eventually he has to stay clean because
he wants to not because of anything that
you're doing um you guys obviously are
not in a toxic relationship if he's the
one with the drinking problem you're not
you don't have to do anything like that
but i do understand her yeah you know
it's like yeah i do i do understand that
and that is very very honorable and if
you do feel like you can do it and you
feel like it would be a thing that you
would bring you guys closer then maybe
you do do it you know if you're not
hurting for money and you don't need to
have that job then then you know but
also real life is real life and if you
do need money and that's the job you
have then he has to understand that and
you know that's what i was to say i mean
it's a job it's a job we're talking
about it's not a certain kind of social
right right this is like this is how you
make a living yeah i'm assuming and so
for him to resent you for having a
certain job
so to make money to support you or the
both of you or whatever i think that
would be sort of out of line for him to
resent you for that yeah uh
i also think that i mean maybe i don't
know because i've never worked at a bar
but is it possible to not drink yeah you
could not drink and then uh i mean they
did it in cheers you could not drink but
uh
and then just go home and not that's
what i mean like yeah that means much
harder obviously but i know but i mean
what i'm saying is i'm going to a gym
and not [ __ ] destroying reps
i don't think that i don't think the
thing is there i'm gonna [ __ ] rep it
out either quit or continue to work and
drink i don't think those are the only
two options i think you have another
option is don't quit and stop drinking
and i think if you're worried about him
that would mean
the most to him
if you sacrifice drinking even though
that whatever you want to call it
temptation or allure is there and you're
denying it for the sake of solidarity
that would absolutely mean the most to
him no if that's not even an option then
i think you shouldn't yeah probably
shouldn't actually quit your job no yeah
unless again you do have the complete
financial stability you don't need that
job right uh but yeah i don't think that
him resenting you for keeping your job
and behaving the way you've always
behaved at that job when you don't have
a drinking problem like he does
ostensibly i'm assuming uh then i think
that's a bit much for him to
resent you for that and if he does
he should bring that up with you and
then you guys work it out so i i
no i don't think you should quit could
you imagine me going into [ __ ] iron
paradise and not pressing it out
uh iron paradise is jim yeah and
pressing it out is bench pressing yeah
or other presses yeah yeah i can imagine
that it wouldn't happen oh what i'm
saying you're asking me if i can imagine
it i say yes if we're in a relationship
me and you okay you can't go to the gym
for [ __ ]
three weeks because for three months
because you got a surgery yeah okay
could you imagine me being like okay and
then driving by every day to work
i go by the iron paradise and not
stopping in and just pressing it out for
20 minutes i can completely imagine that
you can imagine me not going 100
even bodyweight stuff anything
that would never happen so my point is
in solidarity with you i might be like
i'm not going to go to the gym but i
also might be like i'm not going to the
gym and still drive by crunch a few days
and just rep it out really quickly and
not tell you about it but you won't be
able to tell because i don't stink of
anything using alcohol you stink of
alcohol that would be dishonorable
though what you did it would be but also
i'm helping your addiction on your
addiction that's true you'll be lying
for a good cause and you'd also also be
like what's up with the traps dude i
noticed that then uh exactly you get
caught you go like this i thought we
were in this i know we were in this
together but
it's like
your shoulders go on for a week no
so what's the deal no
no
are you i'm gonna ask you point blake
are you
are you driving by crunch stopping him
for 20 minutes and pressing it out
[Laughter]
so dumb you know what are you all sweaty
with the tank top on one of those low
ones where you can see my nipples and
i'm just like nipples
no
with a gym bag
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right all right cool
what's up matt and chris appreciate what
you guys do
um chris definitely been down for a long
time matt i love the podcast that used
to have so quick question
i'm the youngest 41 year old that you
guys know there you go but i still have
a huge sneaker habit whoa you know
whoa oh nice and my question for you
guys is the grateful dead 41 year olds
should i still have a big sneaker habit
should i sell these away and use them
for things towards the house other adult
type things
i love them though i'm a huge sneaker
guy chris i know you're a sneaker guy
matt i'm not so sure but
kind of cares what you guys think so uh
oops
hey dude so disrespectful you think
disgusting
uh hey dude you think the off-white
futura calaba you think
you're good
you're good now off-white for turkey
watch out with the drink dude
just a tempting face so hard my point is
and i don't even wear black with light
shoes so you gotta why not because i
don't like the way it looks but you're
doing it right now i had to wear them
you okay i could have wore a light stop
throwing your shoe on that i wore a
light shirt last time i didn't want to
wear a light shirt this time so but i
wanted to wear these i can see that so i
just go like this nope
oh uh in a sitcom you think a sitcom
about shoes
[Music]
so dude but uh bro does it spark joy you
watch merry condo does it spark joy if
it sparks joy keep them you got those
grateful deads those are beautiful dude
i wish i had the ones he was showing
yeah nice and so does it spark joy also
here's the other thing that i always
wonder about shoe shoe guys and and
cause i'm 42 and people are like why do
you wear the heat you know what i mean
like why do you [ __ ] wear the heat
bro put on some loafers or whatever the
[ __ ] 42 year olds wear no one says why
you were in the heat but why they do
they go oh you got that you oh it's what
are you walking on coals they go like
does it hurt right yeah how about them
blisters buddy i know what you're saying
dude no one says it but the whole thing
is
you don't get money until you're older
and when and heat is expensive okay you
can't afford those grateful deads when
you're 23. okay you can afford them now
too how much when he held up the show
how much are they
that shoe yeah
i mean at least 600 bucks i think let me
see they might be they might be i don't
know what they are now that's a lot of
money yeah i don't
care
about you about shoes
so
i but i but i still agree with chris if
you love it
i mean unless you're hurting for money
which is possible
but
if you love it keep the collection and
don't sell them if you're hurting for
money
obviously [ __ ] sell them because
they're shoes
so size seven is nine hundred dollars
whoa
size ten is
which is the most common is 960 bucks
my size which they make one of per
shipment which is 13 because i got a
[ __ ] you know i'm in charge when it
comes to the downstairs area okay um
1890 what yeah so size 13. and that's a
[ __ ] large like two [ __ ] g notes i
mean what we're talking about from my
belly button to my knees
it's cramped three legs
it's cramped you did a third shoe
so it's like 2700 total
mm-hmm yeah
uh wow that's so expensive yeah
sometimes i there was one time
where i i'm not trying to brag but like
my [ __ ] gets so crowded down there that
one time sounds like a bragga's club no
it's not a brag but one guy there was a
guy i was just sitting on a on a [ __ ]
i was waiting i was waiting on a plane
and i was i was waiting on a plate i was
in the [ __ ] terminal and i was
waiting delayed and dude this guy next
to me kept putting a [ __ ] camera on
my head and i'm like what are you doing
dude i finally the first time i was like
get out you know what the [ __ ] you know
and i just can't be i must be crazy why
would i be putting a camera on my head
that's a great question yeah and and he
finally kept putting the camera on my
head and i go hey buddy what are you
doing and he goes whoa he got scared and
i was like shocked he was so scared he
said i'm sorry i thought you were a
tripod
and i said
oh
yeah you know
so he was like
i get it you're crowded downstairs and i
go and i was like oh so you didn't even
know i was human that's why i got scared
when i started talking he said yes
at the same time it was at the same time
he said because tripods don't talk oh
okay i
don't believe you
that that happened guys try to put
cameras in my head all the [ __ ] time
just twisting it
twisting it on top of it what's up
trying to twist you around
it was running
that is so stupid wow
[Laughter]
wow if a guy picks me up
they instantly think that guy's a
cameraman
okay well no one ever picks you up
because
what the [ __ ] no one else gets you up
no one ever picks up an adult male human
um but yeah
okay what did he ask again oh yeah i
don't even know who the person was i got
so lost uh the shoes the shoes oh yeah
yeah you don't
unless you need money don't sell them
you love the shoes you love the shoes
keep them make you happy
this life sucks wow find the things that
make you happy and hold on to them do
your time [ __ ] you're talking about
this lifestyle people think i'm a
[ __ ] tripod no yeah yeah that's true
anyway all right next one
hey matt hey chris huge fan of the
podcast you guys literally keep me sane
while i'm at work so thank you chris
my baby for life so it's my husband
um my question for you guys is about
relationships slash marriage
sex
um my husband and i have been together
for almost nine years got married young
had kids young in back to back so
our kids are three and a half and two
and a half we're slowly seeing some more
independence and freedom come back that
we used to have
but the number one thing that has
changed is
our sex life so
straight up my husband
would like to have sex every single day
and for me that's just not realistic
so i guess my question to you is how do
i meet him in the middle how much is too
much how little is too little
you know we're trying to figure this out
and obviously i want to keep him happy
at the same time so it's just been the
number one thing that we are bumping
really we have completely different
views on it wow so any advice would be
great
wow that's the number one thing huh
first of all
every day it all sounds real normal
sometimes it's the woman who wants more
sex sometimes it's the man everything's
normal once a day
is
not i wouldn't call it abnormal but
not compromising
yeah true it's like the guy needs to
your husband needs a [ __ ] compliment
so i want to be on the dude's team
because you know
but it's just i can't i want someone i
gotta be more of a person here seven
times a week yeah 365 times a year come
on
it needs to be more i think it should be
three four times a day no i um you need
to do it a thousand five hundred times a
year let's talk about once a week okay
let's start there well
start there i said what do you mean
start there once a week or her her
started well they're coming out once a
week together it's like [ __ ] sex
shark tanks he has sex five times a week
she has sex twice a week they're a
couple they all have sex the same amount
of time yeah no no but i'm saying for
her to be like i'll give you once a week
that's what you're saying her you got to
come to the table a little bit on the
[ __ ]
but my question for her is how much does
she want to have sex she left it out
yeah i bet she's like i just i'm not you
know i bet that that's the deal so she's
gonna meet him a little bit that's what
i'm saying also but here's the other
thing dude if you're anything like me
dude if the guy's anything like me i
don't want to have sex with somebody
that doesn't want to that's what i
that's what i never understood about
[ __ ] this kind of [ __ ] it's like you
know
you hear stories like this and it's just
like but but here's the thing i get it
if he's like
but but it's not it's he wants to have
sex once a [ __ ] day but but it's
different but when it's like what
happened to our passion
like that let i need to you to try to
rediscover that that's much much more
valid but to be like i don't care that
you don't want to have sex with me i
want it once a day that's like
that's like [ __ ] 19. well we don't
know what is what he's saying but she
said it what do you mean no no she's
saying if it were up to my husband he
would like to have it once a day it's
not necessarily like he's henry the
eighth i watch the tutors and when they
[ __ ] he would be like this is what
we're doing and you have to abide by
that okay but um
yeah dude i don't know i mean also
there's other thing
foreplay is every tell this guy this
foreplay is everything you do before sex
not just in the bedroom it's everything
you said that before it's buying flowers
it's doing other things it's it's
setting your uh alarm for when you wake
up it's well no but turning on the hot
part uh the hot faucet so it's the
water's lukewarm when it comes out of
the sink it's not necessarily that i'm
just saying it could be everything you
do up until you have sex in you got to
make your partner the focus of
more
i bet
who is this who's this for is it for her
no for him i'm saying i bet
i bet
there's a thing here where if he were to
focus on you more not just sexually but
in a romantic way
you would um
want to have sex a little bit more i
think maybe not and if not then it's
something else but i don't know if um
so you're saying
the problem is the sex the problem might
be the connection but it's say going
with that would you say that
she should suggest to him
more foreplay and she might be more
likely to want to do it yeah be more
romantic be more present during the day
during the non-sex times you're saying
she should tell him yeah
uh i think you should just tell him
start i think you should just start with
once a day is unrealistic
because we're married and have been
married for a long time and we're not
19. it is uh and so
what let's come up with some kind of
compromise
whether that is once every
if once a week is outrageous so he's
gonna go like i mean it's okay so maybe
if he does that maybe once then what
would you like maybe once between monday
and friday and then once on the weekend
like that might be fine for him but
again i i also come back to the thing
chris said which is like
why is this
guy trying to [ __ ]
when you don't wanna i get he would like
you to want to right and again talking
to her about rekindling some kind of
flame starting foreplay doing things
that make her happy to make her sort of
more excited about having sex but like
to just be like we're [ __ ] today and
we're [ __ ] tomorrow we're [ __ ]
every day and that's what we have to do
to satisfy me i mean of course you don't
want to
who the [ __ ] that's what i'm saying yeah
that's not a connection yeah but there's
others you have you not only have a
valid point to say that's too much you
have a valid point to be like well why
would i want to
yeah like this is not like some exciting
new relationship like do something more
money don't treat me like i'm just a
fried butterfly right like what is that
think about what a fried butterfly i did
think about it pink
why do you well now it's pink think
about a fried butterfly if it were pink
now what this sounds like i need more
things what does it look like if the
fried butterfly foods there was a slit
in the middle of it
[Music]
you're just talking about describing age
restricted you're gonna you're just
describing a female genitalia there we
go okay i could have said that if i want
to be you know well that would have been
way more clinical i'm just saying
if
that is a stupid-ass way to say well you
would try butterfly with a slit in it
okay wow so don't just treat me like
you're so inelegant you know
he's just like wait what uh what
what about a fried what
okay
a a a pink fried butterfly with a slit
in it that you dropped in water
and took it out and it's
and now it looks like that
the worst writer the [ __ ] worst
spitballing a poet skip on poet do you
understand if i read a book with and it
said all that would be my favorite book
dude so [ __ ] off man that would be so
the best [ __ ] i gotta write that up
really so bad but he um yeah just yeah
be open and talk you know guys struggle
talking about this [ __ ] too so uh but he
doesn't have a struggle saying once a
week once a day yeah so
this [ __ ]
have a word with this [ __ ] it's
a lot but yeah i mean
i understand guys a bit much dude
okay
uh well are we done we're done and i
wanted to thank you before you even
look boom yeah so i was gonna say that's
what i was gonna say spin move mentality
t-shirt boom with the spin move totally
in the fern and people know what's up
dude when you watch it the other ones
are the [ __ ] you know what my favorite
is
is the i love this but i love the gray
crew neck is the [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
icons and i'll take it right now that's
the key art that's the number one seller
is it it must be it's the best [ __ ] that
there is also
hey everybody i'm book it up fast get
your [ __ ] matt deleo.com one-on-one
advice sessions
get me i will
listen to you i will love you i will
give you the great advice that i have
from my heart and my head because you
deserve it thank you very much
i
i love you okay um so yeah um i'll be in
uh stockton oakland uh wash or no
that'll be done uh peoria illinois so
about a pitching yourself
because i'll be it just comes out sunday
hi it's sunday i had a good time in
washington dc learning english
uh savannah georgia i'm coming i heard
it's beautiful i'll be there get your
tickets at crystalia.com tempe arizona
uh i'm actually doing the club there
just to pick up a date um
and uh raleigh north carolina can't wait
can't wait to bring that's done that's
dope raleigh north carolina tickets
chrisley.com boston
massachusetts
um that first show sold out we got the
second one on sale bragging um not so
good so it's a seven thousand tickets
total and so uh i'm in albany new york
and then i got that guy i'll see that
guy in lakeland with his [ __ ] hell
yeah that nice ass guy oh that was nice
that was the nicest guy yeah i'll see
that guy all right um yeah and subscribe
to this channel bro we can't get up
[ __ ] ever since we took it to super
cold
people are like i think people are like
what the [ __ ] is this and some
unsubscribe and then more subscribe we
can't get by [ __ ] we've been
whatever number it is above the number
it needs to be at subscribe people like
and subscribe leave a comment uh and uh
if you have a question uh go to lifeline
is lifeline.com
watchlifeline.com uh submit a video
to ask us a question give you the
advices or if you want private obviously
you know what to do yeah and then get
that off on the pure spectrum gummies or
see the show notes for details okay guys
send it so fast
[Music]